ago when from living in his van to
living his [__] dreams ladies and
gentlemen Make Some Noise sing it if you
know the words this is Han him
what the [__] is up comedy by the [__]
hell yeah
[Music]
I think one of the most racist things to
ever happen is the Chinese expulsion Act
do you know what's worse to an Asian
than getting expelled
nothing
could have at least called it the
Chinese b-plus act
how dare you use the language of schools
against us
school is like our NFL
that's like calling the Fugitive Slave
Act the offsides on the defense five
yard penalty Act
I have a Rolex I love my Rolex because
I'm fabulously wealthy
I'm thinking of having kids just a stunt
on people
I love having a Rolex because I can look
at it and be like oh it looks like it's
time to pull up my iPhone because I have
no idea how to read this thing
thank you
[Applause]
welcome another new minute very fun the
Chinese expulsion act yes I've read a
history book this week
I love it what is the Chinese expulsion
act exactly can you explain it to these
uh people
the Chinese expulsion Act is
what happens when Asians act up
is that really what what it
well apparently we built the railroads
and they were like okay what are you
gonna do now okay [__] off you know they
were kind of done with us
I thought you were very funny and I've
made it my live stream to fight racism
[Laughter]
Jim how do you do that exactly
I just don't want to get canceled I'd
say that people would think I'm a good
guy I do want to get canceled get me the
[__] out of Hollywood you're a very good
writer very funny thank you Jim you're
welcome I appreciate uh that you love uh
hating racism I I also agree with you
now Hans you talked about the Chinese a
little bit and you are Korean
[Laughter]
I had to do that I made a show called
Two Broke Girls and there was a Chinese
character on it and the actor that
auditioned was South Korean and they
called me racist
well hey can you please make a call and
fix that look at the nail in that coffin
and they called me races
wait you're not even Chinese I mean I
knew that yeah we were talking are you
really Korean I'm South Korean yeah oh
cool hey [__] Korean all right yeah
Korean Korean Korean Korean all right
there's no difference between North
Korea and South Korean it's just
politics you're Korean you're Korean
how's that going oh where do you live I
live in Georgia on the border of Florida
the same you're a redneck let's
[Music]
I heard Korean Facebook's [__]
confusing as [__] is this true is Korean
time to attack yourself in a photo
you're like is that me
is that my mom
like [__] I'm in all these pictures
[__] Mardi Gras baby
you know at one point in my life I would
have enjoyed that joke
[Laughter]
wait you really are Korean yeah okay yes
get top come on yeah of course
what do you think he's wearing a
Halloween mask or something right now
actually I'm American
[Music]
I am American
ah
I love the guy in the cowboy hat no
you're not yeah no but we're up from boy
all right this is Texas this is not the
rest of America no but I'm all kidding
aside thank you for that learning moment
thank you Jim
how did it feel up here whole different
venue do you notice anything different
you notice the change in the room at all
I noticed that I'm closer to the
audience I feel it's more intimate I
feel like we could really connect
uh and I felt like uh this is a
wonderful club and I can't wait to just
be here and not get not like get you
know extra like kicked out so what do
you extra kicked out extra kicked let me
can I say something really quick yeah
yeah women talking Texas
um
depends on what you say we might edit it
out later
but yeah you can talk now sure we don't
doesn't mean it's gonna be in the show I
have a voice made for podcasting men
love it uh no but I'm half from Texas
I'm my mom's from a place called Sherman
Texas anybody is anyone from Texas that
lives here from here anymore no it's
Austin
it's awesome none of these people are
from here so something I feel like we
all came we're so excited to be at this
club because this is
this thing ever and I feel like we're
like so excited and like pushing and you
just [__] kicked it and one of the
things made me laugh the most you just
went I have a Rolex
and you're just like let you let us set
up be a punch line like that was [__]
so Korean dude
the way is no way
Hans Kim we love having you start the
show you're a consistent [__] real
stand-up comedian yep
Hans Kim ladies and gentlemen
and now I repeat in this back Alleyway
is
189 human beings waiting to find out if
their name